[Música]
hoy 4 de agosto se cumplen 2 años de la
explosión en el puerto de beirut en la
que estallaron 2.700 toneladas de
nitrato de amonio causando una
destrucción generalizada más de 200
muertos y 6.500 heridos la sociedad
libanesa continúa exigiendo respuestas
sobre las causas de la tragedia
tendremos reporte desde beirut
quienes responde con maniobras militares
de fuego real a la visita a taiwán de la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi que
ya se encuentra en japón país que
denunció que cinco misiles chinos
cayeron en áreas de su zona económica
el secretario de estado estadounidense
anthony blinken participa en la reunión
de la asociación de naciones del sudeste
asiático en camboya desde allí reiteró
que su país se opone a cualquier
esfuerzo unilateral para cambiar el
estatuto de taiwán
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 si rodrigo se dan hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos este
informativo en el líbano donde se
cumplen 2 años de la explosión en el
puerto de beirut el 4 de agosto de 2020
estallaron 2.700 toneladas de nitrato de
amonio causando la destrucción del
centro de la capital más de 200 muertos
y 6.500 heridos este jueves varias
marchas recorrieron la ciudad para
exigir respuestas sobre el suceso y
mejoras en la calidad de vida en un país
que vive una grave crisis económica que
se ahondó tras la explosión nuestra
corresponsal en el bonete tiene más
detalles
este 4 de agosto los libaneses han
salido a la calle por muchas razones
para recordar a las más de doscientas
víctimas de la explosión del puerto de
beirut para exigir que haya un proceso
judicial limpio para poder llevar a la
justicia y que rindan cuentas los
culpables y para exigir mejores
condiciones de vida
ahora que los libaneses cada día son más
pobres ha habido tres marchas
simultáneas en diferentes puntos de la
ciudad que han convertido aquí en la
estatua del emigrante donde a las seis y
siete minutos se guardara un minuto de
silencio por las víctimas por parte de
las autoridades no ha habido ninguna
conmemoración oficial
simplemente se han limitado a dar
mensajes de apoyo a los ciudadanos
libaneses por la mayor tragedia que han
vivido en su historia ya pedir que haya
un proceso limpio de justicia algo que
los libaneses ven como una treta
política
justamente en el momento que los
manifestantes estaban marchando aquí
hacia el puerto otro de los silos se ha
derrumbado siendo este el quinto desde
el pasado domingo y el colapso de los
silos
como una metáfora de la negligencia del
gobierno por no haber protegido a sus
ciudadanos y por no haber sabido
proteger el puerto de beirut la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
llegó ya japón luego de reunirse con los
líderes políticos de corea del sur en
seúl pero si evitó hacer comentarios
directos sobre las relaciones con
beijing y taipei que podrían aumentar
aún más las tensiones la líder demócrata
y su homólogo surcoreano emitieron una
declaración conjunta en la que mostraron
su preocupación y enviaron un mensaje
conjunto de disuasión frente al
desarrollo armamentístico de corea del
norte de
la relación entre eeuu y corea del sur
es fuerte y aprendemos uno del otro en
nuestros viajes hablamos sobre seguridad
y agradecemos a nuestros hombres y
mujeres en uniforme por la contribución
que hacen a la seguridad
pero también venimos a decirles que la
amistad que la relación que comenzó de
la urgencia y la seguridad años atrás se
ha convertido en la más cálida de las
amistades y
también discutimos el problema nuclear
de corea del norte ambas partes
expresaron su preocupación por la grave
situación de la creciente amenaza de
corea del norte acordamos apoyar los
esfuerzos de los dos gobiernos para
lograr la desnuclearización y la paz a
través de la cooperación internacional y
el diálogo diplomático basados en la
fuerte y extendida disuasión contra el
norte que nuestro pueblo realmente puede
sentir a la guerra resumida por su parte
china prosiguió con las maniobras
militares con fuego real que realiza
acerca de taiwán en represalia por esta
visita de nancy pelosi a la isla durante
la jornada japón denunció que cinco
misiles chinos cayeron en aguas
pertenecientes a su zona económica
especial nuestro corresponsal en beijing
adrián foncillas tienen los detalles
la visita de nancy pelosi ha
desencadenado las mayores maniobras
militares de la historia en una zona el
estrecho de formosa donde no han
escaseado hasta esta semana contaba tres
grandes crisis china ha lanzado 11
misiles a aguas taiwanesas una medida
que no había tomado en casi 20 años y
tampoco es habitual que sus barcos
crucen la línea media que funciona como
frontera oficiosa taiwán ha denunciado
ese bloqueo de facto que está
entorpeciendo el transporte marítimo y
que ha obligado a varias aerolíneas a
redirigir sus vuelos los lamentos
también han llegado desde japón que
asegura que cinco misiles chinos han
caído dentro de su zona de exclusión
económica precisamente hoy china ha
cancelado una reunión que iba a mantener
su ministro de exteriores con el de
japón de la razón más probable es el
escrito del g7 y del que japón forma
parte en el que se acusa a pekín de
utilizar como pretexto la visita de
pelosi para incrementar su actividad
militar en la zona ha respondido china
y sus medidas son razonables y legítimas
ha acusado a eeuu de causar la crisis
actual y ha dicho que nadie puede
sorprenderse porque ya había avisado
varias veces de las consecuencias del
viaje de pelosi la última vez fue en la
charla presidencial que mantuvieron la
semana pasada xi jinping y joe biden y
desde el martes israel mantiene
bloqueadas las entradas y salidas a la
franja de gaza luego de la captura de
uno de los altos mandos de la yihad
islámica palestina en cisjordania según
el primer ministro en funciones yair
lapid el cierre que busca evitar
cualquier represalia no se extendería
por mucho más tiempo aunque se ha
reforzado la presencia militar con
soldados drones y su habitual sistema
antiaéreo cúpula de hierro nuestra
corresponsal en jerusalén yanira gómez
muñoz tiene los detalles
por tercer día consecutivo israel
mantiene cerrados todos los pasos a
gaza' desde carreteras fronterizas hasta
líneas de tren y el cruce de erez la
medida se debe a posibles represalias
que podría tomar la jihad islámica
palestina por el arresto en cisjordania
de uno de sus líderes más anp saadi
ocurrido el lunes durante una redada
israelí en yenín desde la serie de
ataques de finales de marzo el campo de
refugiados de yenín se ha convertido en
un foco de las operaciones de las
fuerzas israelíes y en este último
durante la captura de saadi los
enfrentamientos también causaron la
muerte de un joven de 17 años en este
contexto la jihad islámica ha elevado su
estado de alerta y preparación mientras
israel que considera el grupo
organización terrorista lo tomó como
amenaza directa con posibles ataques a
civiles y lanzamientos de misiles
antitanque este jueves tanto medios
israelíes como palestinos han reportado
que israel ha desplegado drones armados
sobre la franja algo que se suma al
llamado de cien reservistas como
refuerzo mediadores de egipto y qatar
están ya intentando evitar una nueva
escalada y a través de ellos la yihad
islámica presentó tres demandas que la
familia de saadi pueda visitarlo y
verificar su salud que cesen las
incursiones israelíes en cisjordania
ocupada y por último que se libere a
jalil aguad a un palestino en huelga de
hambre que está en huelga de hambre como
protesta por su detención sin cargos ni
juicio del lado israelí el bloqueo ha
dejado aisladas a dos comunidades del
lado palestino más de 14.000 gazatíes
con permiso de trabajo en israel han
quedado encerrados y la falta de
combustible agudizaría los apagones
eléctricos que están durando más de 10
horas sin contar la parálisis que esto
supone para la entrada de ayuda
humanitaria
el secretario de estado estadounidense
anthony blinken estuvo presente en la
reunión de la asociación de naciones del
sudeste asiático asean en camboya desde
allí reiteró que la política de eeuu no
ha cambiado hacia taiwán y que se opone
a cualquier esfuerzo unilateral para
cambiar el status quo de la isla link en
advirtió que una escalada militar no
beneficiaría a nadie incluidos china o
los miembros de la asean
eeuu sigue teniendo un interés
permanente en la paz y la estabilidad en
el estrecho de taiwán nos oponemos a
cualquier esfuerzo unilateral para
cambiar el statu quo especialmente por
la fuerza seguimos comprometidos con
nuestra política de una sola china
guiados por nuestros compromisos en
virtud de las actas de la comisión de
taiwán los tres comunicados y las seis
garantías y quiere subrayar que no ha
cambiado un lado de nuestras posiciones
y espero de verdad que pekín no fabrique
una crisis ni busque un pretexto para
aumentar su agresiva actividad militar
la estrella del baloncesto
estadounidense brittney griner fue
condenada este jueves en rusia por
posesión de drogas y sentenciada a nueve
años de prisión luego de un juicio que
se produjo en medio de crecientes
tensiones entre moscú y washington por
la guerra no crank ya en medio de una
propuesta de un intercambio de
prisioneros entre washington y moscú el
juez también impuso una multa de un
millón de rublos equivalente a alrededor
de 16 mil setecientos dólares antes de
ser condenada la deportista dijo que
cometió un error involuntario al llevar
marihuana en su viaje a rusia
entretanto el ejército ucraniano afirmó
que rusia podría estar preparando un
ataque sobre la región de gerson en el
sur del país donde ha estado acumulando
fuerzas asimismo informaron que sus
tropas han mejorado su posición táctica
sobre la ciudad de slogans en el este
ucraniano al tiempo las autoridades de
la autoproclamada república popular de
donges que denunciaron la muerte de
cinco personas tras un ataque de la
artillería ucraniana sobre la ciudad
y en un contexto de inflación
desenfrenada en gran parte del mundo
naciones unidas- hizo un llamado para
que los gobiernos analicen la imposición
de gravámenes a las petroleras el sector
del hidrocarburo viene experimentando
jugosas ganancias desde el inicio de la
guerra en ucrania por cuenta de la falta
de disponibilidad que ha disparado los
precios el secretario general del
organismo las acusa de asumir una
posición inmoral
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres acusó a las empresas de
petróleo y gas por obtener sus ganancias
a costa de los más pobres según él una
actitud inmoral hago un llamado a todos
los gobiernos para que graben las
ganancias excesivas y usen esos fondos
para apoyar a los más vulnerables en
estos tiempos difíciles e insto a las
personas de todo el mundo a enviar un
mensaje claro a la industria del
combustible y sus financistas esta
avaricia ridícula castiga a los más
pobres y vulnerables mientras destruye
nuestro único hogar común el planeta
mientras que la inflación ha afectado
las finanzas de los hogares a nivel
global desde el comienzo de la guerra en
ucrania según la onu las ganancias de
las grandes hidrocarburíferas ascienden
a los 100 mil millones de dólares sólo
en el primer trimestre del 2022 al mismo
tiempo
345 millones de personas están en riesgo
de la inseguridad alimentaria gravar los
beneficios de los gigantes del gas y del
petróleo una opción que francia ve con
buenos ojos el miércoles fue aprobado un
proyecto de ley de poder adquisitivo una
bonificación de 30 céntimos por litro de
combustible frente a los 18 céntimos
anteriores una medida destinada a ayudar
a los hogares en dificultad según el
gobierno la ley también prevé un aumento
del 4 por ciento de las pensiones de
jubilación y varios mínimos sociales
otra medida es la triplicación del bono
macrón en el cual las empresas estarán
eximida de pagar impuestos hasta finales
del 2023 en islandia entró en erupción
un volcán situado cerca del centro de la
capital del país lava al rojo vivo y
columnas de humo se pueden ver desde
hace algunas horas tras días de
actividad sísmica el lugar se convirtió
recientemente en un popular destino
turístico pero las autoridades llaman
ahora a residentes y visitantes a
abstenerse de acercarse al área ante la
actividad del volcán
a 40 km de la capital de islandia
reykjavík lava al rojo vivo y columnas
de humo salen de una fisura volcánica
para deleite de los intrépidos turistas
que estaban allí y presenciaron una
escena espectacular
he esperado años y años para ver la lava
es el objetivo de mi vida
y cuando llegamos a esa colina decidimos
bajar vamos a acercarnos y es un riesgo
y lo sabemos pero lo vamos a hacer
creo que voy a llorar porque es muy
bello y muy emotivo maus la erupción en
la península de réquiem ee se produjo
tras un periodo de intensa actividad
sísmica con unos 10.000 terremotos
detectados desde el sábado hasta el año
pasado la zona no había experimentado
una erupción desde el siglo 13 se cree
que la actividad volcánica de este año
es entre 5 y 10 veces más fuerte que la
de 2021
tienes los cráteres abiertos tienes la
fuente de lava y luego la lava que fluye
que en realidad también está empujando
la arena y la tierra delante de sí misma
así que esto es realmente espectacular
me gusta mucho
las autoridades islandesas evalúan los
peligros incluso la posible
contaminación por gas al tiempo que
emitieron advertencias para los
visitantes los geofísicos afirman que la
actividad reciente podría marcar el
inicio de un nuevo período de erupciones
que duraría siglos
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a france 24 y frases 24 punto
com
[Música]